pink in mi b qui a buttare la vacanza
sta scaricando ancora ma può mai
scaricare un registro di scasso intanto
non la metto da parte taglio il video fa
vi è tagliato il video vero e tagliato
questo primo pezzo dove non stabili vero
che hai tagliato vero che l'hai tagliato
che non è mai partito così col video di
mika non sei partito goodfellas di
ragazzi e prevede che sono video sono fa
vj enti sono stipati simulator 2015 dato
l'audio è bellissimo chabrol
antisemitiche colonna sonora degna del
gladiatore sei come un ragazzo è una
roba tipo surgeon simulator solo con il
tè è fatta meglio di sergio un simulator
la mano non ci posso credere il
pupazzetto no però grazie ecco
è una roba tipo selphy cos'è self il mio
dio la ciao the di tutto a posto
senti io devo fare che il tè mi dai una
mattata sembra che ci abbia dei problemi
alla mano cosa stai facendo 0
no questo è un piatto no di riprendere
no ai biscotti da il tackle di scotti
non è male la prima servirebbe il te
allora siccome si chiama tesi moti
simulator no rovesciando tutto dammi la
mano non guardarmi così non guardare
d'armi ragazzo di mano un pupazzo
inutile
dammi una mano a susa non è che non sia
bravo guarda che se inutile il cazzo non
devi dormire sui cocci della teiera devi
darmi una mano qualche canino che dorme
ma come come posti no scusate mi lega ma
se sono seduto sul tavolo come possa far
così io non sono un essere umano sono un
braccio è di tutto a posto guardata bene
alti peggio nella vita potresti scoprire
di essere un braccio da un giorno
all'altro e non è bello così come no
scusate di nuvole protetti cosa fa il 90
atene dove da che ati parti a morte due
ragazzi da zero come si deve piano piano
prima di tutto accendiamo la radio eco
perfetto stop unicredit smettila di
farmi sembrare cattivo in questo istat
ma non sei cattivo te dio ti voglio bene
ti voglio bene è una lavatina ragazzi la
gelatina preso vita a caso
ok no si perfetto diventa canestro ho
fatto che né del pensi thing cosa vuol
dire piano ragazzi già sto facendo parte
i canestri alla michael jordan e le
gelatine che si muovono dov'è andata non
regga dove l'ho già ecco eccole qua
sotto e questo tu cosa fai di voi sa un
po di te anche tu gelatina merda o
sbagliato e el e si è rotta nuova
1 o cazzo meno male nessuno è morto meno
per quanto ne sappia io no stai
tranquillo e morto the di sé gonfiato
tipo la zia di harry potter scattategli
facciamolo bene sta cosa prima di tutto
vi facciamo piano senti ma [ __ ] ce
l'ho fatta versa versa versa se il gesto
faceva vero sporcato di tutto ma ce la
sto fatto che acqua realistica sembra
palline di cose poi ditemi come delle
palline possano sembrare acqua
spiegatemelo com
vabbè [ __ ] la teiera tanto non
serve la soletta a è qua dentro qua
dentro perfetto prendiamo piano che è
ben lontana piano con la z da una è che
cazzo però ci provo ci riprovo
tranquilla non ti inglobare tu il tappo
della teiera se tranquillo ok bene piano
piano ok
e che cazzo però you buffon io buffon ma
che cazzo diceva del piero al massimo un
che buffon non faceva ridere c'è una
barca il mio braccio non va oltre questo
punto pensavo di essere mister fantastic
ma proprio che arrivassi lontanissimo
invece no arrivo fino a qua continua
pure ad andare tranquillo che io faccio
il tesi o tranquillo per poi voglio
provare aprir salta gasto scrigno vedrà
chi cazzo è proprio dopo che devo fare
il tempo che ha forse inzupparlo anche
così ass
perfetto che con la tua è quel tuo si
sarà fatto il tecnico llano o devi
togliere solo la zolletta anche se non
col cazzo
no
capitano la cazzola torta andata giù è
andata 2 andata giù perfetto piano ok e
non c'è più un cazzo
va bene è le chiamo il tavolo le chiamo
il tavolo perché tanto è rimasto quello
da fare chiamata guarda un po rallo
planina dove arriva ariano aprì la
boccuccia apcom sei incazzato
vabbè ti regala il biscotto a rallenti
bellissimo vedere che cos'è sta cosa e
terni un cilindro fatemelo mettere a
teddy ascoltati o se come ci stai bene
l'ha messo un coltello ragazzi cè un
coltello che non avevo visto stop making
luca stai tranquillo zio ci penso io
adesso chiudi gli occhi
anna si è in casa manolo bucato ragazzi
o troppo amico mio alte te lo fai da
solo ma veramente ragazzi gli occhiali
da mlg meglio io o mio dio che gentleman
come lo sto tenendo madonna non so come
ho fatto a prenderlo così mariano piano
posa da te proprio premi rimbalza alta è
che bello il tech e riba che fisica che
c'è questo gioco incredibile l'acqua
rimbalzano fatta
ciò fa ragazzi giovate adesso mi prendo
il mio l'ho fatta sei ubriaco cosa no
zio non sono ubriaco sono intelligente
non come te cazzo ok va bè ragazzi vi è
che l'ho picchiato per l'ultima volta è
possa andare avanti perché sono
finiscono non c'è un pesce sotto come
buona la torta zio ecco qua perche tutto
tuo wire mangia ma bevi mangia fa quello
che vuoi bilancio anche scusa zio e per
concludere tutto ragazzi l'ottima
gelatina che ti incorono così perfetto
il pesce che ci sta sempre alla ragazzi
quando fate un key parti quando fatto un
party con il tè è sempre il pesce sempre
è obbligatorio quindi il pesce per dare
sapore perfetto adesso te lo puoi bere
zio colpe parti lascio anche lui così
sono insaporisci quanto ha comunque
ragazzi con cavo episodio e sa per
quanto strano giocare a riparti
simulation
ed ecco bravo tanto politico zio guarda
qui che bella persona fa o mio dio
lo ho fatto un casino cela la pianta che
rimbalzano la palla manco fosse
ronaldinho e robben che ecco qua buffon
buffon
milano sono proprio cazzo buffon anche
ragazzi è stata alquanto strano giocarci
credetemi è il gioco credo della storia
il più bello del 2015 buffon
[ __ ] lo guarda lo guarda guarda
ggc g7 paratone sotto l'incrocio che
adesso il buffon che è il buffon adesso
di melo ho detto smettila di essere più
forno non smette di essere buffon perché
sono bravo a parare da dai ragazzi
concluso che l'episodio è stato alquanto
strana spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto per ogni mi piace che mettete
una parata in più per gigi è una in meno
per teddy lo ridotto pranzo fatti
picchiare da una donna sexy non dire che
ti lamenti ragazzi spero che ha visto vi
sia piaciuto con l'assetto sentito è
piaciuta al salto momento vi piace anche
la passione facebook e cavani l'ho
trovata una descrizione sono ostacoli si
di skyteam i civili da uno pro soluto
bella ragazza
[Musica]